A yakuza?
BA-DUMP
Keep your mouth shut.
And no eye contact.
Do you have a Blu-ray box set of
Crimecatch Policure?
Poli…
Yes, of course,
and there is plenty in stock.
By the way, which season
of the Blu-ray box set would you like?
Because there are three versions
of the Blu-ray box sets.
This is my own personal opinion,
but I would recommend
the second season of Policure.
That's because both the second season's
animation director and scriptwriter
also worked on the highly acclaimed movie.
Also, here's some geeky info.
The director continuously used
a manga style targeted at boy audiences,
so it was worth watching and innovative--
RUSTLE
Here's the money. Get me the goods pronto.
I have my own bag.
And can I have a loyalty card?